oui championnat du monde bonjour santé
mentale tv avec lorlanges bonjour loi
bonjour stephen bonjour à tous donc
chaque pièce du monde qui se passe aux
chiottes on peut le dire je crois qu'on
peut le dire c'est la suspicion des
chiottes un grand match oui maintenant
il ya donné des nouvelles théories de
jour en jour le complot s'intensifie
enfin plongeon c'est terrible histoire
de base c'est que donc rester topalov
annonce par l'intermédiaire de son
manager silvio danilov qu' il ya des
soupçons sur le fait que vladimir
kramnik soi et b qui devrait donc placer
des émetteurs dans les toilettes quelque
chose qui permettrait de récupérer un
signal venant d'un ordinateur
surpuissant qui lui annoncerait les
coûts
probables avis donc selon le camp
topalov la dynamique de vos toilettes
beaucoup trop souvent oui voit pourtant
souvent alors et daniela faut six
sorties sorti un truc complètement
incroyable il a fait une statistique sur
les coûts de kramnik il a dit dans la
partie je sais plus quel parti il a et
67 % des coûts qui sont les mêmes que
ceux qu'aurait joué le logiciel de
frites ont fait ça veut rien dire quoi
j'ai un champion du monde en plus
topalov autant d'accents louis ski où il
a gagné son titre avait des scores bien
supérieur puisqu'il était proche de 90 %
des coûts de l'ordinateur donc c'est du
n'importe quoi dans tous les sens
effectivement de dire que les coûts sont
similaires à ceux proposés par jonathan
n'a pas vraiment de sens dans la mesure
où il s'agit de l'un des meilleurs
joueurs du monde qui sont censés jouer
les meilleurs coups donc en fait on ne
peut pas reprocher à un joueur de bien
jouer y aurait là c'est aberrant sûr
c'est assez gras blocs effectivement un
match qui se joue pour l'instant pas
forcément sur l'échiquier mais c'est
comme dans tous les grands championnats
du monde il ya toujours des paramètres
extérieurs qui entrent en compte
effectivement c'est toujours pareil
kasparov et karpov être psychologue et
par un psychologue les présidents de
russie il s'en mêle parce que c'est
plutôt karpov porsche noire elbeuf
kharkov quand je n'aurai exact y avait
aussi à l'époque que fisher spassky pour
travailler le soir dont il avait des
mouches électronique derniers examens il
ya toujours eu dans ces grands matches
de championnat du monde des éléments
extérieurs
donc non pas que je cautionne ce que
fait un silure danilov qui est
effectivement problème en prêt à tout
pour remporter la victoire quel coach
donc de topalov qui utilisent des moyens
douteux mais n'empêche que ce n'est que
dans un petit peu de piment au match ah
oui ça vous rend met ça en mai ça
rajoute un peu hein les parties sont de
qualité de toute façon
pas toujours très bien le délire kramnik
aussi volontiers super tendu et en plus
on a un peu d'animation autour ce qu'il
fait alors certains diront une mauvaise
presse moi qui est vrai que ça fait la
une de la presse où ça fait de la presse
de toute façon ça fait de la presse
évoluent assez clair cédé à côté mais
enfin on aurait aimé que ça se fasse
d'un quand même dans des conditions où
kramnik en tout cas ne perdent pas par
forfait à limites que les suspicions à
nantes le match à la limite ça a
toujours été le cas kasparov suspecter
la fidh aussi davantage et carpeaux à
fond le sait ça a fait beaucoup parler
des championnats du monde à l'époque
maintenant il ya cette histoire succès
un ordinateur à noter que tran nghi que
contre attaque en défense puisqu'ils
suspecte de caen
topalov danilov non pas d'utiliser un
ordinateur mais de mettre des trucs
électroniques dans son camp pour faire
croire que voilà c'est à dire que donc
mais on n'a toujours rien vu de toute
façon il n'y a pas de tentation du
nombre de micro ou encore dans les
toilettes oui donc ils se préparent
chronique et quand vous en trouvez un
mois je pense que c'est l'équipe en
phrases qui a noté que maintenant cravic
c'est donc tronic 7 août s'exprime
toujours lui-même mais il fait un peut
intervenir sont des raiders carte hensel
mais on notera donc 2 approche
complètement différente dans le conte
opale off c'est toujours si le dos d'âne
ilove qui parlent en même temps qu'il
fallait rien à l'urgence ne dit jamais
rien il ne le dit jamais rien il répond
juste aux questions techniques sur la
partie d'échecs c'est tout une sorte de
l'échiquier alors si on les admire
kramnik lui est bien s'exprime sur tous
les à-côtés du match un avis sur tous
les sujets et parlant le temps de ces
partis le manager de blagnac kramnik
donc à dakar steinsel lui reste assez en
retrait et s'occupe de grosso modo faire
les plaintes officielles et ainsi de
suite ouais mais on peut on peut voir le
duo parfait qui est représenté par dan
idof topalov loin sur l'échiquier et
l'autre anderlecht voilà alors que caen
kramnik il est obligé de s'occuper alors
que planning apparemment qui est en
train de se disperser un petit peu dans
ce match à mon avis est ce que 400 elle
ne ferait pas peut-être son travail 100%
aussi il a peut-être pas il appelle
habitude n'a pas la catastrophe il est
là depuis longtemps est un défi celle de
tous les championnats de tous les trucs
donc effectivement haut niveau entertain
m
un manager connue reconnue ce qu'ils ne
craignaient depuis quelques années
depuis temps l'écho aussi ouais mais
c'est pas tout à fait pareil et
s'occuper de crédit capital locaux pour
l'heure invitation au tournoi de
dortmund qui est bien organisée qui est
nickel et qui marche depuis des années
c'est pas pareil qu'un championnat du
monde a les listes à silvio danilov en
face oui il est pas préparé à ça
certaines salles c'est un problème un
bon manager un départ à réparer à ce qui
lui arrive maintenant voilà c'est ça il
va falloir qu'il peut être
mais je lis que son avis d'ailleurs que
c'est que c'est qu'il acquit la wii qui
l'a envoyé des plaintes officielles
aussi de son côté donc là encore une
partie en dehors de l'échiquier qui
continue on aura toujours ce point que
parfois fait qu'est ce que va donner ce
point parfait je pense qu'on va en
parler dans les six mois qui viennent on
est peut-être même l'année prochaine
encore en fonction des retombées en tout
cas on est après la sixième partie
selon la régie de nice selon le score
10e officieux au fait je sais pas je
sais pas quoi dire avec ce point par
forfait mais trois et demi deux ans et
demi selon les organisateurs selon les
organisateurs mais selon la police voilà
c'est ça c'est la pluie non mais on a
déjà vu même des matchs de foot par
exemple désavoué par des tribunaux
civils donc je veux dire on peut très
bien avoir un tribunal civil hors lequel
je sais pas la cour européenne en sais
rien moi je sais pas
quand tu es bon laisser ça là et listes
indépendantes qu'elles courent
supranationale ça je sais pas
effectivement on peut se poser la
question mais bon on peut très bien
imaginer la fidh et en suisse en août la
vie des résidents suisses enfin le noyau
dur de la fidh est ensuite donc
dépendants d'une justice suisse moi je
pense que c'est là-bas que la plainte
sera déposée
alors évidemment krasic est peut-être
kramnik à allure peut-être raison de
jouer si dans sa tête il abonde dans ce
sens si je gagne le match ça sera pliée
je porterai plainte quand même pour
récupérer des sous et si je perds le
match peut toujours encore porté plainte
au cas où voilà donc il pétait il joue
sur cet ami de l'homme est là mais alors
ça stéphane tout le monde le sait quand
on accepte de continuer après une
décision défavorable une décision une
décision d'arbitrage défavorables ça
veut dire qu'on l'a acceptée sinon on
refuse de continuer c'est impossible de
porter plainte après ça ne marche jamais
tout simplement des cas des cas
c'est malsain ça peut être ça peut être
mal c'est rappelons nous quand même
marseille valenciennes
en football dont 92 juste avant la
finale de coupe d'europe marseille gagne
sur le terrain je crois 1-0 et sur le
papier sur tapis vert je crois qu'ils
ont perdu 3-0 en fait voilà donc ça
arrive quand même donc il faut quand
même se méfier de ce qui peut arriver
alors en tout cas on voit cette
maintenance est septième partie dans ce
match extrêmement tendu entre topalov et
vladimir je ne faut pas que je tape sur
la table dit on enrichit donc je vais
éviter de taper sur la table on va
passer dans cette partie entre topalov
et vladimir kramnik alors topalov a de
nouveau les blancs et laurent caure les
blancs
nom n'aura pas les blancs dans la 8ème
et safran saf c'est la troisième fois
consécutive c'est la blonde 300 de ses
coutumes de la partie où il a bel et
bien il a été légué un forfait tout à
fait voilà donc ça c'est du jamais vu
des 4 donc on continue et on va voir les
mêmes premier coup des 5 donc c'est qu'a
donc on voit ses salles à karachi dans
le match pour ça que les kasparov ou les
cramique tiennent tant à ce que le
champion du monde se décide en match
c'est que c'est pas du tout pareil que
jouer un tournoi d'abord c'est le même
joueur en face et ensuite il ya une
stratégie de match on va jouer l'hymne
d'ouverture pour dominer l'adversaire si
on arrive à le dominer sur son ouverture
principal c'est très dur après que cette
ouverture où il ya une dimension
supplémentaire dans les matches qui est
évidemment l'équipe de spécialistes qui
travaillent en bas de grandes qui
travaille pour le joueur et qui eux donc
ils les deux équipes semaine lutte
frénétique dans le domaine des positions
de couverture on va dire que l'équipe
topalov ils sont 10 avec les ordinateurs
et tout et tout ils travaillent 7 slave
l'équipe chronique pareil il travaille
aussi la slave et donc ça donne
effectivement des parties d'un niveau
extrêmement avancé dans les ouvertures
sur 7 sur 7 à noter d'ailleurs que
bas relief et ziegler je crois on
rejoignent pop alito pas au large et
aériens krainik peut pas l'y faire en
revanche krainik a highly star pour le
supporter oui alors je procède pour
l'aider mais les deux joueurs russes
donc peter si les variables sont
affligés complètement par cette affaire
des toilettes il trouve ça scandaleux
ils ont décidé d'aller et des planards
chronique voilà de le soutenir même sans
être payés donc parlera par pure volonté
de le faire est rare que les russes ne
table pas sont là il faut pas que je
tape certain et c'est rare que les
russes fassent des choses sans se faire
payer alors donc ces quatre ces six
cavaliers le trois
quarts et m6 et larmes et a eu droit
donc la tombe à l'eau varie encore donc
il essaie de surprendre cramique
par des changements comme ça d'ouverture
la dernière fois il avait joué mais il
ya des choix qui a laissé trois kelkoo
principal accusé kai c3 et après il
avait joué avec a rallié aux 5 c'est ça
voilà donc les jeux qui est étroit et il
avait eu cette fameuse ouverture vieille
ouverture remise à la mode par kramnik
qu'on peut comparer à la berlinoise
qu'il avait remis à la mode contre
kasparov un vieux truc une position très
simple très solide et donc topalov
l'équipe topalov à chercher ils n'ont
pas trop ils ont rien trouvé pour les
langues moi j'adore l'instant et robben
ils peuvent y revenir il reviendra
certainement là c'est ce qu'avait fait
aussi
kasparov et c'est ce qui se passe pour
la recherche une solution mais ici s'y
trouve une faille ils vont revenir assez
pariente alors que 3 o6
donc fou détroit et la comprends ces cas
classique on attend que le fouet jouer
pour prendre ces quatre ici parce qu'une
fois que le fou joue une fois évidemment
la reprise fait que la pièce joue deux
fois donc c'est quand même mieux que de
prendre alors que le fou est encore sur
la sa case de départ oui si c'est une
semi cela tout à fait normal français
cadres et là tout de suite c'est 5 c5
transpose dans un gambit dame accepte et
on a commission de typique du combiné à
accepter ce qui va se passer c'est que
vladimir kramnik vont encore échanger
des pions centre ou don qu'il veut
changer la science c'est entre dès la
reprise des blancs normalement la
reprise de topalov sera avec l'option ou
et on arrivera dans un lieu isolé mais
comme c'est la partie on va y venir on
va y venir maintenant l'idée de
principal de vladimir kramnik dans l'est
dans son choix d'ouverture c'est
toujours d'échanger des points centraux
et d'obtenir une position les pièces
s'échangent bref il veut neutraliser
vesselin topalov tout simple et puis
éviter les préparations trop haut trop
aiguë exact en fait un chrono qui veut
éviter les complications il ya certains
types de pollution ou vesselin topalov
est très impressionnant très très
spectaculaire c'est les positions
d'attac notamment les positions les
pièces se replace et les positions où il
ya des leviers pions extrêmement
complexe et là en tout cas
tandis qu'ils arrivent à éviter en
général la taxe sur le roi est le levier
plus loin mais ça veut dire qu'ils
jouent vraiment quand même clairement de
façon défensive et jérémy joueurs aussi
jeunes joueurs bien sûr vous voir dans
petit rock à 6 donc là la menace noir
c'est sans doute de jouer des scènes
tout de suite et peut-être après tout
mais c'est un développement normal qui a
si c'est un coup extrêmement naturelle
dans cette pression effectivement il ya
des baies 5 qui arrive de temps en temps
des 5 celui de ces quatre ça peut
arriver des cinq fours bessette comme tu
l'as dit stéphane de toute façon on est
toujours content d'avoir mis deux pions
envahissent alors four b3 on anticipe ou
n'anticipe b5 qui en prend des 4e prend
des cas donc logique pour libérer le fou
mais mes problèmes enfin le problème
afin disait caractéristiques de la
position c'est ce fameux qu'on appelle
plus isolé puisque on voit bien plus y a
pas d'option à côté pour le protéger
donc il va être tout seul en est qu'il
est isolé contrairement par exemple aux
pions 17 qui lui est toujours soutenu
par le pion à 1 par exemple sur les cinq
sens soutenu par le pion ici ce pion
nécessite ce pion des câbles nécessite
des pièces par exemple ici la dame et le
cavalier pour être en défense donc
ça peut être un souci par contre
avantage c'est qu'on a une colonne semi
ouverte ici une couverte là donc on a
des avant-postes en c'est simple et ans
le 5 oui alors c'est fn on va reprendre
grosso modo tout ce que tu viens de dire
parce que c'est très important de bien
comprendre cette histoire de psion isolé
et structures de pions donc ici ou à
nettoyer les positions et on va
recommencer alors il ya effectivement un
tueur isolé en d4 ça c'est une chose il
ya un avant poste qui est la case au
sein pour le cavalier blanc pour bien
évaluer les structures d'options je
voulais revenir là dessus c'est on
compte le nombre de groupes d'options on
voit que les noirs ont un groupe ici
c'est d'options ensemble et un deuxième
groupe i see donc les noirs de groupes
comment alors oui les blancs 1 1 là ça
c'est un groupe puisqu'il est tous amis
la personne à côté et ça c'est un
troisième groupe donc ces deux groupes
contre 1 voilà à droite le gall bâle iii
groupe compte de la 3 contre 2,5 donc
avantage pour celui qui a le moins de le
moins deux groupes donc ici avantage
noir au niveau de la structure de thiant
oui parce que ça fait autant groupe
autant de cibles c'est ça exactement
donc voilà pourquoi l'option isolé est
considérée comme une petite faiblesse en
termes de structure de pions et que si
toutes les pièces sortent moins ya deux
pièces plus qui ont isolé et faible et
ainsi de suite
maintenant les cons en contrepartie
celle attaque on à l'avant-poste sur
cette case 5 comme on l'a dit et en même
temps voit qu'ici un cavani vient
s'installer là le fou pour revenir en c2
le cavalier peut bondir le fou peut
arriver on peut toujours passer une tour
par ici et la dame qui peut passer donc
consommer l'eau à plus ou moins long
terme toutes les pièces blanches vont se
retrouver sur le petit reviendra voilà
ce qui va se passer donc on a pu y ont
fait bien des cas on attaque le roi
voilà le débat si on l'isolé qui est
lancée tout à fait alors qu'avaient
laissé six une chronologie développement
attaque tout de suite d'ailleurs aussi
le clan des quatre avec la dame ça va et
s'est défendu pour l'instant il défendu
et puis on va pas trop après pour
acheter les pièces n'est pas simple hein
parce que ce fou ça va être difficile à
ta question
faudra ramener une tour derrière la dame
on n'y est pas on est très loin de tout
ça car les c3 développement logique
aussi très bien placé davantage aussi
c'est
qu'on a choisi une autre ici que
vesselin topalov menace des quatre des
cinq aux menaces des 5 on peut le donner
à ces normes voilà qui permettrait
d'éliminer les pions isolé en échangeant
canton qui réussissent et qui souvent
donnent un avantage dynamique ou blanc
avec des échecs pour cynthia
supplémentaires un centime voilà mais
par contre ça ça s'ils maîtrisent les
structures de pions donc ça aussi ça
peut être un facteur 2 nuls c'est dire
que par exemple ici si vladimir kramnik
jouer un coup comme des 5
et bien évidemment des cinq deviendrait
extrêmement fort ouvrant toutes les
lignes le roi au centre tous faibles ça
serait écrasant entre les axes donc à
l'essai trois fosses est donc là
tranquille très tranquille un grammy
tourvain logique la tour ici en cas de
décès niort pour y faire pression
parfois sur le fouet cette faut faire
attention à ses possibilités des fois et
en tout cas aussi contre le très bien
qu'à 2,5 qui peut être une case pour le
cavalier voilà donc en tout cas les
actifs cette tour plus qu'en f1 petit
rock
à 4 donc à noter que ak donc empêche b5
et à noter que topalov prend son temps
pour développer son fou alors qu'il a
sans doute pas encore trouvé la
meilleure place pour ce fou qui
pourraient aller peut-être tout à
l'heure vous pouvez peut-être aller 1-3
maintenant qu'est la tour s'est
pareillement une actualité en f4 angers
5 et peut-être des fois même en d2 en
l'occurrence là ce n'est pas possible
mais pour l'instant en tout cas ils se
réservent les possibilités oui à noter
que à 4 et le premier coup un peu
responsable oui c'est un peu nouveau on
va dire si dire c'est sa soeur de
grandes lignes les deux grands coups
sont faut être quatre fois j'essaie
inquiète dans cette position avant un
carnet et de grands coups c'était fou et
4 au fond j'ai singer 5 dans les deux
cas avec l'idée donc qu'on le feuilleton
f4 ces deux dunks de s'implanter avec le
cavalier ou 5 et de reprendre du fou sur
les cadeaux 5 c'est une chose qui existe
est quand on vend g5 et bien sûr
d'augmenter le contrôle sur lauquet
osiatis est donc sur la caisse dé saint
tite donc oui parce que ce cas les
défend la caisse des scènes donc on peut
c'est un coût qui retarde à noter que le
grand spécialiste de cette position
accablant eh bien c'est la dernière
chronique
terre battue à noms de plusieurs fois
avec les bronzes il n'a pas peur
chronique topalov de rentrer dans les
ouvertures avec couleurs inversées voilà
donc où 17 donc continuer à développer
les pièces voilà même si le fou est pas
super bien placé ici mais il est quand
même développé cavalli 2,5 tout de suite
alors maintenant évidemment c'est
l'heure parce que juste avant évidemment
c'était pas possible c'est à dire qu'ici
si je joue cavalier 1,5 le pion lada le
pion des quatre et ont pris cavaliers
prend ou de me prend dans les cartons
étaient emprise défendu qu'une seule
fois car il souhaitait plutôt qu'il
allait vendre qu'elle va les prendre
attaquants fut notamment mais après fou
17 évidemment la dame et s'il n'attaque
plus le plein des 4 et donc on peut
jouer que la bm 5 est alors en cas de
prisons prendrait du pion certains
production minimale le caire 6 2 il ya
plus de quatre ans j'ai dit que j'allais
bientôt la taxe sur l'europe à devenir
il peut y avoir des matches cinq tours
3-1 courage 3 et matin à acheter oui ça
va ça va être très très vite ça va c'est
pas vraiment caricatural ça c'est ça
peut vraiment arriver fouet 8 est là
donc il choisit quand même fou 3 donc
malgré que la tour était derrière mais
quand je ne prêterai été attaqué dans le
pire des cas et attaquer donc on a
défendu ici bon mais maintenant le
chronique aurait pu envisager car les
prend et ensuite d'en prendre il y aura
un avantage blanc n'est ce pas c'est si
important oui et puis en avantage de
développement aussi d'un plan de
développement donc tours suite de
chroniques donc on est encore toujours
vers la fin du développement maintenant
et après tour c'est un voilà je pense
qu'on peut dire que là le développement
est terminé il faut engager des actions
le développement des blancs est terminée
en tout cas ça c'est clair pour les
noirs y ait encore des pièces à sortir
on voit assez clairement que ça c'est
pas la position définitive du fou oui
mais pas pour l'autre ils passent la
tour donc ces familles il faut replacer
sous le plomb en général pour les noirs
c'est d'échanger des pièces oui si on
voit pas trop comment faire pour le
moment
et pour les blancs en revanche on sait
pas trop non plus quels seront leurs
prochains coups en général pour les
blancs ou hp entend sait plus trop quoi
faire un feuillage quatre matches de nhl
6h et si sérieusement et il ya toujours
des voix là c'est en gros c'est sale
c'est ça le plan des blancs dans cette
position il stabilise un peu tout et
puis que son courage c'est donc ici on
voit un coup très logique pour réduire
chronique qui a été joué d'ailleurs
kelkoo quai vallet b4 alors ça c'est
typique des positions depuis rizzoli oui
alors un i pro qui profite du fait que
cette case b4 n'est plus attaquable
n'est plus attaquées par le pion à qui
est allé un peu trop loin car s'il avait
été un à trois mais non c'était pas
possible donc cette cime casse faible et
en fait ils augmentent le contrôle sur
la case des cinq donc en fait il veut
replier son cavalier en d5 proposant des
échanges de pièces voilà tout simplement
et avoir un cavalier bloqueurs c'est
idéal quand en plus isolé c'est ce qu'il
faut faire c'était en in the witch le
père de la théorie moderne qui avait
indiqué cette technique de
de contrôle de l'adversaire donc un pion
isolé et quand même dangereux parce
qu'il peut pousser à chaque fois souvent
pour faire des sacrifices et tout donc
très bien contrôlé sa classe 2 d'avancé
et si possible mettre des cavaliers
demande des cavaliers bloqueurs qui sont
à la fois protéger finalement par le
pion adverse puisqu'on peut pas
l'attaquer directement par une pièce
lourde et en même temps qu'ils
continuent à attaquer le camp adverse
celui que si c'est du classique donc
tout est normal jusque ici maintenant
donc ma mère 3 nov il passe la dame à
l'attack il va mener la dame voit la
soirée commence par 2,3 pour faire
pression sur le pion à vii avec le coût
des trois qui peut revenir en c2 à noter
autre chose aussi donc on a parlé de l'
attaque directe avec le pion h
maintenant on anticipe une dame waj 3
qui serait pas mal de ces braquages 7 il
faut voir que ces attaques sur les sur
le roi noir en général se combine avec
des attaques sur le pion aux six seriez
d'écueils point f cette fois aussi ce
qui marche avec la d'amour h3d fois et
on se rappelle notamment une très belle
victoire de la lumière kramnik contre
garry kasparov avec l'option isolé dans
le match de londres en 2000 où il avait
planté cahiers pour 1,27 à garry
kasparov mois d'arrêt ça marche et ça
marche on crée des cas où ça marche donc
voilà les blancs attaqué normalement et
donc on y passe la table c'est très
logique fossé 6-2 kramnik logique on
avait dit que le fou était pas sa place
ici donc ans et 6 il est beaucoup plus
actif et en plus ils gagnent du temps
sur la dame tout de suite mais mais mais
on dirait elle le désavantage on dirait
c'est que ce fou des prix défensif donc
pour tech - of 7 oui les gens que
stefania une remarque est très
importante c'est que là les blancs
peuvent prendre la peur de fou en jouant
simplement lequel valeo 5 pouces et ici
on peut aussi prendre avec le cavalier
évidemment mais bon en échange d'une
pièce très bien placé et on va quand
même rare rester avec ce plan isolé donc
plus à l échange de pièces plus est
favorable au noir exactement donc c'est
pour ça que c'est très important de
signaler que quand vous jouez contre un
pion isolé
vous ne devez pas avoir peur de perdre
la paire de fonds si vous pouvez changer
ce caillou 5 pouces et 6 il a pas peur
de la peur d'être échangé face à ce
cavalier il reprendrait très
certainement de la tour eiffel ils
bloqueraient avec les cavaliers et après
il va il va doubler ses tours très
certaine et la position serait à peu
près équilibrée
des proches de l'élite alors là topalov
logique joue le coup d'un match 3 donc
on avait prévu
bon c'était facile à retenir c'est qu'on
avait la partie avant c'est vrai enfin
cela dit le coût est normal il est venu
en europe voilà partis pour aller en
acheter alors ce qu'on a envie de faire
maintenant avec les blancs c'est de
mettre ce fou sur cette diagonale
peut-être pour faire pression sur h 7
mai mais il est bien placé aussi
puisqu'il peut pas y avoir maintenant
des combinaisons 06 par exemple tout de
suite on peut même imaginer que pointe
alors imaginons un coût par exemple
comme à 5 ans combinons
vraiment particulier à mon bidon ouais
mais pour montrer la richesse des
preuves montrées la menace qui peut
exister quand même car vallée prend f7
est possible et après tout reprend elle
est tout simplement fou prend 2,6 et on
va récupérer une des deux tours en
qualité bon c'est peut-être pas gagnant
évidemment mais on nous associe pousser
les pions des forêts plus cédé 5 enfin
en tout cas voilà des possibilités
c'est peut-être pas absolument gagner
mais ça devient ça commence à devenir
sont dans l'air du temps et c'est pour
ça que kramnik propose food et 5 voilà
ils bloquent à mes talents avec le fou
pardon je reviens en arrière donc qui
bloque ici c'est des mots n'a donc ils
empêchent le fond d'avoir cette
possibilité de sacrifices il faut voir
que le maître se fout en dessin qui est
bien c'est très clairement provoqué un
échange de pièces là maintenant oui
parce que les virages la toile n'a pas
de casier il faudrait qu'ils viennent
ici on est pas assez changé le coût d un
est vraiment trop mauvais donc il n'y a
pas de choix pour
pour vesselin topalov fil 2g qui veut
dire qu'on fout car il prend foule
d'amis prend il garde quand même la
paire de fond dans cette position est
maintenant cramique reprend de son
cavalier ben évidement puisqu'il garde
ce cavalier à la protection du roi
importante toujours très souvent dans
l'hérault qu'il vaut mieux avoir le
cavalier ici c'est quand même mieux oui
autre point important aussi c'est lui
qui a mené au but 4 était un peu gênant
pour développer du contre jeu c'est à
dire que s'il est que notre cavalier
bien enfin là par exemple en ayant pris
du calibre et il peut jouer d'un v6
c'est un coup un peu pénible attaqué
trois hôtels qui ont sali ça a libéré la
colonne ici un petit peu ça 7/2 colonnes
sur cette position alors tour cédé 1 la
topalov évite un échange supplémentaire
de pièces il oublie pas qu enfin qu'il
est un pion isolé et peut-être il a dans
l'idée aussi peut-être de jouer autour
des 3 et après que ce fou et jouée par
exemple en c1 d'amener sa tour à angers
3 pour attaquer voilà toute façon
topalov qui pensent à la table là il
passe à l'attaqué c'est clair une
position qu'il aime bien les chroniques
elles et pas contre défendant seule gêne
pas trop en fait il aime bien ni un peu
c'est vraiment on a vraiment
l'impression de voir le même si
opposition de style que entre karpov et
kasparov s'est vraiment c'est similaire
c'est bon c'est vrai il ya des petites
similitudes wake est ce parce que
j'étais un peu plus on va dire bourrin
que topalov danser dans ces attaques
baloch un peu plus fin quand même il
joue un peu plus de manoeuvre
on va dire souple kasparov était
beaucoup plus direct je veux dire avec
l'accord
alors tour c'est donc pour pas échangé
tour c'est 7 de chroniques donc
lorsque ou deux tours c'est pour
protéger la septième en mer c'est un peu
ça l'idée je ne pense pas que stephen
les coincer pour sûr protéger
effectivement peut-être cette case 17 il
ya certains cas où c'est l'autre quasi
si
maintenant c'est pour préparer aussi le
doublement tour où la dame derrière ici
pour avoir la possibilité d'avoir un
contrôle très fort sur la colonne s'est
il préparé mensuellement aussi des coups
comme des cinq enfants autour de 7,5 ou
aux multiples fonctions n'y a pas de pas
vraiment de il dit simplement a total of
à toi de jouer qu'est ce que tu me
prépares qu'est ce que tu as prévu et la
capa la fouge et 5 voilà
alors l'idée de fou g5 c'est de pouvoir
évidemment éliminé un défenseur ici par
exemple on pourrait faire [ __ ] en
cavalier d'abord et après par exemple
dame prend échanger sur ce cavalier et
il pourrait avoir apprêté peut-être
d'émanations achète enfants ont droit
comme en ont en fait ce qu'il ne voit
pas comment il faut dire dans cette
pétition c'est que les skins topaloff
est prêt à les changer maintenant c'est
fou contre les cavaliers
c'est une démonstration grosso modo que
les blancs ne risque rien ils ont la
peur de fou la paire de fous plus un
pion isolé en général c'est ça c'est nul
ça fait au moins un nul aurait
simplement en utilisant solide mais les
blancs peuvent échanger quand ils
veulent et faire le don qui s'y faisait
5 un coup logique inactive la tour 1 il
réveille septembre 20 maintenant sept
tours aussi ouais voilà là il faut deux
ans maintenant il ya donc de nouveau des
menaces etc et pourrait fait qu'ils
peuvent revenir quelques jours en asie
puisque après on pourrait prendre de la
dame par exemple voilà exactement avec
cas des menaces dont fujitsu est qu un
peu logique qui prépare éventuellement
des échanges topalov ne risque rien
petit avantage pour topalov encore alors
l'alakran il joue damas évite donc coup
à la fois logique puisqu'on double ici
des pièces lourdes dont qu'on contrôle
mieux la colonne c est aussi la dame
mais protège quand même sept canaux 6
pour éviter ces fameux sacrifices on
n'oublie pas que la dame blanche ici
pour les uns il ya une pression sur
scène quand tu es gosnay avec le fou ici
donc ces cases blanches ici sont sous
pression de la tour de la dame ici j'en
ai de cette flèche là est celle ci ici
aussi du cavalier et là encore enfin du
fou qui par transparence attaques
jusqu'au rang oui ça fait quand même une
grosse pression sur ces cases brabant
qui ça tiens c'est quand même une belle
chaîne de pions solide mais les
sacrifices sont en mer oui je pense
qu'il est important de préciser dans
cette position que j'admire chronique à
chaque coup envisage bien quel point
cette envisage bien tous les coups forcé
en fait tout simplement vérifie rien et
il faut dire que topalov n'a pas de plan
de pion dans cette position il dit il
peut pas jouer avec les pions ou alors
en tout cas c'est pas très très net
ouais c'est pas très toxique ait pas de
combinaison avec les pièces s'il ya pas
de plan de pions et bien tout simplement
condamné à les changer les pièces et
puis faire une piteusement piteusement
dame f3 donc là ça c'est un coup de
louvoiement on voit pas trop ce que
vient faire la dame la
côté estimé qu à eux trois ils avaient
terminé son rôle c'est le problème c'est
que l'on pouvait pas amélioré leur
position c'est à dire que la sortir de
là c'est très difficile donc c'est là
c'est presque au coude à temps pour
magnan est là maintenant le crâne il
joue pour des huit donc ça y est
maintenant il ramène cette pièce
vers le centre dont qui contrôlent
encore une fois d'une faute de plus mon
petit bémol il a fait bien tout petit
peu la can et c'est là qu'on voit un
autre avantage de la tour on sait c'est
que ça qu'on trouvera lario is tour
pariant peut défendre f7 dans certaines
situations hk à travers ça y est c'est
ce que tu disais pas de plans d'options
donc ils en trouvent un pop allofs il
veut jouer sans doute h5 et des trois
mages 6 pour affaiblir le roi noir et la
ccra ligue du nuage ou h6 posant la
question en fout alors non nous pose pas
la question vous puisqu'on ne menace pas
vraiment de le prendre ses saveurs oui
c'est alors rigolo qu'on peut imaginer
aucun coup blanc neutre un couple en
parle comme chez 3g trois chiens non
c'est pas terrible non plus n'ont alors
un coup note c'est pas évident aux
dernières attaques non à 5 alors prenez
un coup d'oeil c'est pas notre donc le
bon choix c'est juste pour montrer qu on
prend fou alors qu'ils ont fait en fut
si on prend qui comprend maintenant si
lecavalier pied bouche il ya deux
problèmes 7 suivi d'un match alors est
ce bien là maintenant il faut que
cavaler bouge alors on parle par exemple
qu'il ya dix huit caillage 7 quel gâchis
7e bateau de course stéphane complément
valent entre justement là mais j'aime
faire rire cet échec d'après hrw sept
maintenant est celle qu'on est protégé
par le cavalier wade que la peau ne
protège pas parce qu'il faut gêne
évidemment donc cesser c'est ce qu'il
fallait voir et maintenant après voyage
suite évidemment c'est que régis is matt
exemple typique le genre de possibilités
dont la le fouille pas vraiment attaquer
mais met alors en fait l'idée de justice
c'est que
ça regarde sa part axel blue peuvent que
j'aurais puisque le feuilleton prise
voilà on peut pas jouer à 100 parce que
la sto fois que vous serez vraiment en
prix
dont clément topaloff même s'il n'est
pas vraiment menacé décide de partir
quand même justement l on peut se
demander est ce que est ce que les
banques pourraient pas pu jouer un coup
vraiment attaque fort comme g4 il se
trouve effectivement stéphane que
le coup g4 et le coût qui est
recommandée dans cette position par les
experts et qui disent que c'était les
meilleures chances de topalov de trouver
de l'attaqué il n'a pas fait ça voilà
parce que là avait après pions prend
à bâle il ya des variantes c'était
compliqué par exemple dans tout
simplement le cavalier doit bouger et
peut-être il peut pas bouger non
justement il faut pas il ne faut pas le
bouger faut pas bouger il faut il faut
sacrifier quand même on va sacrifier ce
cavalier parce que si bout il ya
toujours ce dame prend expliqué plus en
plus graves et puis à vis des projets de
tours h un ouvrage les deux est en fait
un tour à chiens on voit bien que
maintenant que cette colonne est ouverte
qui aurait un match derrière donc ça
serait très difficile apparaît et donc
il faudrait laisser faudrait laisser
récupérer le font déjouer un coupe coupe
et 4 par exemple trouvé quatre voilà
donc j'en prends aussi c'est obligatoire
puis on prend et après
là on laisse la tour ouais bah voilà en
fait c'est compliqué c'est très très
compliqué c'est compliqué c'était
possible c'était possible il n'a pas
choisi sa topalov il a joué phocéen donc
il n'a pas choisi c'est bizarre parce
que c'était pourtant dans son style de
faire ce genre d'attaqué quoi ouais mais
peut se réserver l'option dauger quatre
plus tard toujours au coude après c'est
pas pareil c'est pas pareil c'est pas
bon mais là il faut préparer juste
impossible donc sous ce nom n'est pas
n'est pas trés trés n'est pas encore une
rare au lancement total attaque alors
foulée 4 une embuscade quand il titille
âge de tours où va la tour et bien tout
simplement à la maison voilà ce que fait
ou pas l'offre il rentre à la maison
fou des six gymnastes peut-être
d'échangés ce cavalier maintenant mais
il y aurait pu plus isolé après donc une
belle paire de fou donc ça serait
g3 ne peut pas leur falloir bizarre
voilà là aussi on l'apprend pas
extraordinaire d'ailleurs il n'ya pas de
rouge tant le petit ovale of sur ce coup
là parce que là on a l'impression que
alors je dirais c'est à dire être
délicate ils ont pu jauger cap mais dire
que topalov
joue timide cc complète ce serait
oublier complètement les première partie
du match ouais où il a tout donné c'est
bizarre d'y parfaire voilà donc on va
dire qu'il s'est assagi et un peu plus
prudent il est un peu plus prudent oui
dans la marre de tout envoyer se faire
se faire ramasser voilà ramasser parce
que il en a mis partout et qu'à la fin
des contrats financés soit il a gagné
très joli point par forfait donc ils se
disent on n'a même plus besoin de
prendre de risques il attend la
prochaine victoire par forfait voilà
c'est ce qu il veut c est gagné par
forfait exactement c'est quand même plus
simple il compte sur son coach voilà il
compte sur son scotch qui quand même
état qui prépare une nouveauté
et odette vous inventez je ne sais pas
encore un truc
peut-être pas dans les toilettes cette
femme s'était promis d' idée en tout cas
dans la tête du coach et demi c'est à
dire de sédhiou d'analysé très forte
alors b 6
ouais les deux les dogons tu sais plus
trop quoi faire smic ou d'attentes bon
ben c'est un coût qui
sert pas à grand chose sa faible ça
affaiblit un peu plus on assiste dans le
côté bon
dans le monde tsa contrôle des cases
aussi ben voilà mais ça sert à rien quoi
on va pas trop à quoi ça sert c'est
d'ailleurs tout de suite topalov joue
dames 2 et garde un petit oeil bien sûr
le pion à 6 1,6 à pleurer ça pourrait
être un thème on a vraiment été étonné
quand même dans cette partie que total a
fait pas jouer g4 g5 il y avait l'air
quand même d'être le plan
cavaliers de 7,2 kramnik donc ça m'ouvre
à salou voix on va dire que ça louvois
il va peut-être vouloir remplacer par
l'autre cavaliers on sait pas trop ce
qu'il veut faire en général il veut
mettre le camion f5 pour attaquer le
tour des cats c'est à dire qu'une fois
qu'on l'a bien bloqué on voit la plaque
et où l'attaqué avant l'attaqué
douloureux placement cabrio cette 1re
placements classiques torreilles fin
j'ai vu des centaines de faux alors là
très bizarre ce groupe puisque cramique
pourrait rejouer fourbe et 4 breaks
oisiens semi proposition de news cas là
je ne peux encore jouer au foot et de
évidemment mais ça serait pas bon avec
rupture isolée donc faut prendre 5 alors
là peut-être kramnik a calculé que
maintenant c'était l'heure de simplifier
et après pions prend le 5 ils échangent
encore une tour dames prend et carlier
des 5 dollars il a échangé ses cavaliers
on a vu deux places ou alors c est l
inverse était celui ci ce cavalier qui
était en et 5 maintenant il va même
versé et il a échangé en attendant des
pièces alors là on a une pression qui
est quand même très intéressant de cette
époque j'ai regardé cette partie donc en
direct
et quand la position est arrivé je me
suis dit deux choses je me suis la
première bon les blonds la terre de fou
quand même même salaire important
serrières important donc aujourd'hui -
les cavaliers noirs se tiennent bien
mais je pense que sur le long terme la
paire de faux est importante la deuxième
chose c'est que te pas la façon qu
orange 4 peut jouer h5 à plus ou moins
court terme et ensuite menacé des diètes
et enfin faire des menaces sur les
comptes des gones ailes blanches donc
mon idée ces deux dames détroit et ça ça
pose un problème pour l'instant puisque
dame et tour comprend très bien la
colonne c'est exaltant et donc je me
suis dit bon on va probablement les
blancs sont beaucoup mieux dans cette
position parce qu'on a le père de fou on
a des perspectives de taille sur le
moyen terme donc ici il va y avoir un
avantage non mais c'était sans compter
sur des les cons point fort de la
position d'un chat n'est pas bien vu
c'est que les cavaliers se tiennent donc
à mieux cette des cinq se sont
indéniables la case des s'inquiétant des
logiciels très fort cavaliers gagnent
installé au centre qui contrôle quand
une des cases qui empêche les blancs de
manoeuvrer et l'élément fondamental de
cette mission devient effectivement l'a
déjà dit stéphane c'est que les noirs
ont la colonne s'est tournée cette dame
s'est vite c'est extrêmement pénibles
pour les blancs que vous incarnez la
colonne et ça va empêcher vesselin
topalov de mettre ces pièces sur des
très bonnes perspectives
juste que je dis de replacer mon micro
donc alors fou des deux maintenant de
topalov donc là il redéveloppe sont fous
bizarrement voilà une année en d2 parce
qu'en fait il veut bouger saddam
peut-être oui le penser il était comme
cela était quand même en prison non plus
au fait des deux c'est pas mal ça fait
museau cavaliers dessin ça ça contre le
car est l'un des cinq puisque ça
contrôler les cases du cavalier voilà ça
c'est classique ça c'est un schéma qu'il
faut bien avoir en tête c'est très utile
à la fois on peut dire que le cavalier
domine le fond ou que le fou contre
lequel il ya passé deux pièces se
tiennent en respect
alors
ensuite tour ces cinq là voilà c'est bon
ça c'est des coups dont c'est ça que
c'est pas vraiment inexplicable à
stéphane pour qu'on souhaite à quel
point c'est tout on va t'acheter qui
trahit surtout besoin de justice car j
ça c'est pas non plus un coup donc ici
bon il ya beaucoup de
poussines même c'est cette eau si on va
attaquer la maison c'est leur puisqu'on
a joué food et 2 on peut jouer d'alger
quatre ans il joue dame g4 et il menace
quand même donc faut prendre 6 6 ont-ils
menace puisque il y aurait ici il ya un
vis-à-vis qui fait que le pion est floue
et dont je sais que tout est le fameux
clouage donc ya comme une menace ici et
la chronique joue logique se sert de la
mobilité son cavalier d'où aussi l'idée
maintenant comprend aussi bien pour ses
5 qui protège des cinq cavaliers 25
voilà maintenant sur faut qu'on croyait
on peut prendre de la tour sans casser
notre rupture de pions et la cavalière
elle protège à la fois g7 est aussi
surtout h6 donc on ne peut pas prendre à
noter évidemment que la pression reste
très tendue ici c'est tendu ce point ce
n'est pas
celle des pièces de
table 4
recentralise l'a d'ailleurs peut-être
que maintenant il veut jouer peut-être
j'ai quatre attaquants de cavaliers oui
je joue surtout hashtag d'abord vais
d'abord jouer 5 h 5 puis j'ai 15 h 54
voilà une possibilité et après j'ai cinq
pour casser le rock il veut te qu'il
veut attaquer attaquer des cinq pétales
en chronique c'est leur canton la taille
d'un côté les fonctions réagir de
l'autre donc kramnik veut pas laisser
qu'ils attaquent un peu notre côté ici
il veut échanger ce qui apparemment bon
achten quand même et après pions prend
1,4
topalov choisi de reprendre avec la dame
me prend 1,4 et il veut peut-être
maintenant il peut faire pression sur le
pion à cissé - peut-être avec tours 1
faire pression ici mais ce pion serait
fait exact les des possibilités il
fallait bien reprendre d'une certaine
façon docteur prix de la dame pour b52
kramnik un titre et surtout b2 alors
attaque le fouet un oeil sur le pion b2
voilà il faut il faut menacer la baisse
est quelque chose d'assez important
c'est que
topalov astucieux sont des champions et
h5 ce qui fait que maintenant il a des
pions sur quatre blanche qui détient sur
4 noir oui ça veut dire que quels que
soient le fou qu'ils échangent contre un
cavalier l'autre fou restera à moitié
bon à moitié mauvais donc quand on a le
deux fous contre deux cavaliers c'est
très important de la défiance d'un côté
sur blu ray de l'autre sur noir la
gradation des deux côtés d'aquarelles de
casser afin qu'ils soient très forts et
le fou très faible c'est d'accord faut
que les deux fous sur un peu fort donc
ici topalov a fait quelque chose d'assez
malin ce qui fait que chaque fois qu'il
joue à fond des 5 par exemple et bien le
food ne sera pas complètement idiot
puisqu'il aura un petit ami sur http à 6
pour pas être complètement idiot
exactement force et anouk la up on
attaque la dame donc logique d'un
bessette qui a l'air très fort puisque
ça attaque le pion le foot est roi et
par transparence le pion b2i d'ailleurs
un passage que par transparence la dame
elle arrive vers le roi blanc et la dame
effectivement ici on n'en savait rien au
lait des livres des cases tout à fait
intéressante non qu'on a affaibli avec
g3 un peu ces cases blanches avec l'aide
d'un cavalier des 4 par exemple un petit
échec l'as aorai très pénible à contrer
donc poussé deux ici de topalov est là
eh bien on a l'impression quand même
mais loi que ce plan b de 8 ans prise
que se passe-t-il surtout pour mes 2
alors tour en vélo il ya un problème
stéphane quand même passé immédiat alors
tout reprendre les deux donc il ya des
huit échecs qui est d'actualité quand
même c'est à dire que c'est un des coups
qu'on peut faire échec à vous pour m5
également y aller donc pour l'heure
assez intéressant un peu dans le même
ordre d'idée puisque la valeur va
arriver après voyant d'un boyau d'un
prend 1,8 oui dans ma vie trois sets et
maintenant cinq échecs fou promis 5
échecs le seul coup c'est d'oran et
maintenant le coût ces tours s'est vite
pour ces 8 et sa menace un math ici on
voit que le roi ait pris grâce à ce
petit pion qui l'empêchent de sortir
d'où la salle aux militaires il a noté
le panneau dans le cercueil à noter
quelque chose une variété importante
c'est qu'il ya toujours dans ce genre de
position la ressource suivante qui est
tombé un échec donc là il faut pas se
tromper il faut pas aller sur les
casiers de pastore qui a valu aux trois
doubles échecs semi nomades oui il ya la
glace avec la dame bien sûr donc après
rouages de maintenant faut toujours
calculé ce qui tourne chez à oui on
reprend cavaliers ou trois échecs si
l'on croit bien ici ou là et bien là les
deux dames âgées de maths baiser de la
main mais mais mais mais ici il ya
interceptions ouais il y avait un autre
coup il les a secoués loi c'est cavalli
c'est cet échec
alors y avait qualifié cet échec les ait
sur ton échec ici qu'elle et ses sept
quarts laisser cet échec au roi
qui est pas mal et puis pas mal puisque
maintenant donc il ya dame la dame fait
un échec la découverte et la dame
adverse à être prises et en même temps
avec le cavalier on a empêché le
contrôle de cette case donc est en fait
mais en fait il ya tout simplement je
pense ces lois sur dame sur tourbe est
un échec en fait on rejouait phocéen
c'est dans cette voie là on protège et
on menace toujours matt donc obligerait
les noirs à sacrifier la qualité
voilà la réponse à la question
alors on va regarder le coup suivant
oui et alors donc c'est bien a bon
stéphane c'était à l'avancé on sait en
flat des anciens flammes et on est parti
on va revenir la préfère que ces deux c2
donc il y avait cette possibilité au
congo qui ne marche pas à cause d'eux
justement le dam de virton mais de le
voir la variante à cause de dames 8
royal 7 comprend échec qui on prend un
tour c'est 8 menace maths et même sur
tourbe et bien il ya quand même fou
c'est un il arrive langage il ya
toujours le même la droite et alors donc
ici qu'elle épaississe donc là il a
choisi d'abord qui avait six attaquants
la dame
quand même bizarre parce que d'un côté
ça ça ça désactive la puissance sur lui
de vous faites c'est très technique ici
c'était très tactique le fait est que
les blancs doivent repartir avec leurs
dames et que les 4,4 et maintenant pour
prendre les devants la salle et donc il
a pris quand même champions notre ami
cramique donc il faut faire attention
avec les blancs mais ils m'ont quand
même la paire de fouet il ya quand même
une attaque sur se voit on voit bien par
exemple food prize 5 fu prend 1,6 voilà
il commence à y avoir des choses fouet 4
d'avoir tout de suite on attaque la dame
adverse permet de gagner un temps et
après dan 17 il faut évidemment protéger
ce fou qui est attaqué par la dame et
par la tour donc on joue fou hein alors
c'est très curieuse qui s'est passé
parce que en l'espace de quelques coups
on a l'impression que les dessous de
topalov ne sont pas vraiment inquiet
qu'il a perdu un pion et qui en revanche
la dynamique s'est retrouvé qu'une tour
sur la seconde option passer tout ça est
cueilli sa main passe avec maintien de
passer une tour en d2 oui mais en fait
il ya quand même une pression car il ya
une petite praticiens son néant le
politologue s'est dégradée dans les
derniers comptes il cessa pas forcément
obligé de deux espions b2 qui n'a pas
géré au moins y'a pas géré au mieux donc
la chronique choisi calais des cinq donc
ils recentrent maintenant il ramène son
cavalier vers le centre donc ça a l'air
vraiment intéressant et après fou des
trois
oui ici c'est y avait la possibilité
aussi de jouer dans cette position qui
est 2 3 il ya beaucoup de possibilités
on a cette possibilité là qui existe
ouais par exemple cavaliers ou trois
attaques la dame est en cas de prise ça
casserait la structure blanche et la
dame prendre il faut voilà en direct y
avait beaucoup de joueurs qui posent qui
donnait cette possibilité mais
effectivement il semblerait que dame
4,24 ici protège le fourgon remède et le
cahier toujours attaquer dray par g4 son
taux est quoi revenir en arrière donc
dès maintenant duras g4 et il y aura il
y aura aussi j'ai 4 nages et 4 avec
derrière un gros d'un match cet échec
directement donc notons que c'était sans
doute d'ailleurs la menace dans la
position ici c'est pourquoi crown il
joue tout de suite calais b quatre
attaquants le fou et on voit que ce fou
a pas beaucoup de cases il faudrait
revenir son bien à bien ça fait peur ça
fait peur parce que et que la tour
protéger il suffirait de dévier cette
tour et en veut car sinon et surtout
maintenant il ya un problème c'est que
quand le fou vient bien par exemple
stéphane il peut y avoir imaginé un oui
l'astuce qui avait libéré quatre mais
enfin qu'est des cas tu aurais peut-être
d'avocats donc peut-être un coup comme
dam des cinq plus tôt
theiler possible dam des cinq ici
attention attention est loin alors qu'il
ya toujours les astuces avec tours ces
vidéos attention il y aurait un pseudo
mat du couloir avec quand même le fou et
la dame ici que les contrôles donc c'est
vrai qu' il faut faire attention et très
attention
quand ils sont quand même là il faut
quand même faire attention c'est vrai ça
avait l'air possible peut-être un coup
tout simplement comme cavaliers detroit
qui propose une fourchette ici wiki et
des transports dans la partie
apparemment probablement que se
passe-t-il par exemple ici sur sa propre
rhétorique le parti d'ailleurs on peut
regarder la partie est ce que tour des
uns est possible par exemple tour d un
ses comptes ouais c'est ça mais pourrait
prendre le 5 tout simplement ça
ressemble à la partie donc on va revenir
on va revenir à la partie il est midi là
des signes avec le fond f1 qu'il
apparaît il a choisi de mettre son four
et femmes et bien aidé semblait possible
aussi bien il a choisi f1 et après
cavaliers detroit donc on revient dans
la partie donc attaque à la fois la tour
et le fou donc il faudrait cloud et
cette dame finalement ici alors soit par
la tour soit par adam le problème se
retourner un stéphane on vient de le
dire tour d un c'est que le cou
cavaliers detroit ponction et s'attaque
la dame blanca les points 5
la dame est attaqué par la tour mais
mais mais la dame adverse aussi par le
cavalier donc ça ça équilibre tours
pendables cavalli brandam et on a deux
pions de plus ça commence à faire
beaucoup oui donc il choisit d'âme des
uns d'opale of africa les détroits il
choisit d'amd 1,7 fois évidemment site
cavalli prend la tour la dame est perdue
donc là il ya un vrai clouage d'ailleurs
on alors de se dire que médian yacou loi
j'ai on voit pas trop comment un
cramique peut s'en sortir en cela dit
toutes les forces et donc on peut
regarder les qui suivent effectivement
les y ai pas le choix pour défendre bec
et détroit il faut choquer les
pronostics n'ai pas d'autres cavaliers
prendre 5 donc prendre qui ont au
passage et propose un échange de dames
donc à peu près pareil ça se ressemble
il a crâne et au palais accepte les
changements qu'il a quand même 2 kg en
moins weight topalov à tous donc enfin
tout cas donc là à temps plein de lutte
quand même pour la nulle un
sas en attaque disons à leur marché noir
et son culte pour le voir on a
l'impression qu'on a l'impression
d'apprendre 17 car les prenez cette
logique et maintenant le fameux lapointe
tour c'est 8 voilà ça y est cheikh et on
voit que
ya problème parce que il ya que deux
possibles solutions pour les noirs donc
soit 3,7 soit qu'elles les fuites qui
serait très pacifique que les fuites a
pas l'extraordinaire pour être jugé
dangereux il pourrait être pris après il
suffirait que ce fou arrive sur cette
diagonale ici quelque part et c'est
grave et ses références en est la
défense auxerroise 7 est quasiment forcé
et maintenant tour csn voilà donc la
tour c 7 le câble est attaqué et
derrière il ya le pion à vii en
transparence il n'y a pas de moyens nous
bloquions 1,6 également étant prises
pour le foot et le plus raciste en prise
par le fou donc qui va récupérer un pion
et au bluff est là d'ailleurs c'est là
je pense que oui on peut se dire que
c'est là que topalov que kramnik a
peut-être raté cette la suite il a
peut-être pas joué le plus
le plus précis bon c'est pas facile mais
c'est à dire que cette position mais
quand même
ça va être nul ça va mais pouvait contre
attaque les chroniques quand je prends
le coup cavaillé
psychiatrie attaques et pillages 5 et
qui aussi parfois pouvait aider parce
qu'à val et des cadres qui peut sauter
ici sur la case des quatre pour finir
faire des échecs en f3 il y avait des
possibilités oui mais bon d'après les
les années visées moussa cervantes
saint-valère possible ça s'engage vers
la nuit quand même après fou précise par
exemple ici limits option à difficile de
défendre le plus est il ya des très très
bonne chance de prouver ce n'était pas
l'homme mais il est évident maintenant
stéphane que c'est la dynamique qui a
repris l'initiative près cavaliers 6
imaginons une possibilité que fufu prend
1,6
maintenant toujours des tours bien on
peut commencer par tour bien on peut
commencer par tour bien on peut
à noter que sur calais prochain qui aura
toujours le coup j'ai quatre tours fait
un geste attaque le fou donc qui est
cloué donc ça oblige à roy est fin et
maintenant maintenant il ya tout détroit
qui va revenir attaquons la tour bien
pour le cavalier l5 le pion à vii et ix
emprise bref les bleus ont suffisamment
de jeu pour espérer sortir là nul de
cette petite pour espérer mais c'est
quand même c'est pas assez pas simple
quand on les détruit très bonne chance
au new deal très bonne chance de nous
laisser ça aurait été possible en tout
cas kramnik après tour c'est cette a
choisi de jouer tourbains la contre
attaque alors tu m'attaques lecavalier
je t'attaque le fou
est là
topalov a choisi de faire dicter
l'échangé trouver un truc est au top
alors d'être une sorte de forteresse on
va voir les coûts qui suivent sont à peu
près sûr c'est tout reprendre foudre
kung fu tour championnat pour prendre le
problème en question maintenant à 5 pour
empêcher évidemment le fou d'avoir prise
sur le pion quand on commence à aller à
dame en commun ça allait à dame bien
suivre la projet deux mois j'ai deux
rois g8 à jacques latour repas bah dis
donc le roi et corinne très mal placé un
match 7 il pourra jamais sortir angers 6
à cause du pian donc il veut approcher
son endroit un peu de cases plus central
on va voir donc non de coûts de
maintenance et du retour à 7 dans la
logique en attaque le pion on se met
derrière le pion toro 5 force est
quasiment il faut protéger le pian j'en
ai toujours mieux placé peut-être ici
que là ici la toro était l'opium aussi
et pour protéger ce plan mais sur un
tout à fait
ici est très important encore g4g quatre
attaques lecavalier qui est calé des
6es après fou détroit voilà là je crois
qu'on est dans la position
où on peut dire que les noirs n'ont plus
plomb c'est à dire que l'option à cinq
ne passe plus ce plan peut pas avancer
il est bloqué par la torah cette voie là
le roi noir ne pèse plus parce que quand
ils viennent environ les fuites il est
intercepté par fuji 6 est ici le fou ici
voilà va venir en justice pour empêcher
le roi de progrès c'est exactement ce
que c'était le roi le plein du roi ce
serait d'aller ici évidemment à en
bessette et la tour sera obligé de
partir et ça libérerait le pion oui à
noter qu'à ce genre de plongée cette
employée bien aussi ce qui rend donc la
tour blanche est très forte le fou blanc
extraits mon puissant le ciel est noir
n'a pas de gaz locale ne peut pas
s'améliorer les blancs ou encore une
option qui est poussée le pion l'efs
éventuellement le fou est plus fort que
le cavalier parce qu'ils ont partout
donc ici équilibre dynamique et il ya
plus de plan pour personne matériel
contre équilibre et comme on va le voir
aucun des deux joueurs n'a pas joué
encore quelques coups wife 8 fou g6 donc
ça va ça va louvoyer mais vous allez
voir que personne n'arrive à progresser
de 5 pour kramnik donc on voit karl
avantage aussi avait que cinq pour
kramnik ces canidés sur noir donc c'est
quand les mieux le pion contrôler les
quinze mois et le cavalier contre les
cases blanches ce qui fait un véritable
mur que ne peut pas passer le roi blanc
donc ils empêchent leur rappelant de
progresser après deux tours des deux
échecs roi 20 tours dé 5,2 il peut pas
avancer lui-même cranie tombé 5 on voit
que ça louvois mais il y aura pas de
solution tour des cinq tours à s'être
voyez ça revient et après tour b 5 fu
des trois tours des 5 fu g6 une
troisième fois le troisième problème
aussi c'est nul c'est parti nul voilà
donc belle partie topalov attend telle
attaque on peut dire que kramnik l'a
bien repoussé puisqu'il a même pris un
avantage matériel mais que le dynamisme
de
duke en blanc pour topalov a suffi pour
équilibrer le match où ils topalov qui
passe pas très loin de la
correctionnelle -une fois plus quand
même pas très loin que il est passé par
les positions assez douteuse mais
continue sa stratégie sur l'échiquier
topalov qui est une stratégie très
agressive
il continue à jouer à fond quand même
toutes les positions il prend j'avais
les yeux par la pétition coup il
continue toujours à mettre la pression
allait devenir chronique il joue au
physique comme d'habitude
est ici bas pour l'instant le match est
pas évident parce que c'est à dire quand
même bien engagée pour crâner qui passe
gros favoris comme malgré sa défaite par
forfait parce qu'il faut quand même dire
que topalov sur l'échiquier n'a gagné
aucune partie pour le moment nouaille
chronique en a gagné deux topalov on
avait zéro oui une part faible un
dernier gros favoris à ce stade du match
exactement surtout quand on approche des
deux tiers du match exactement la
tournée à la joue et qu'on est la
septième partie il y en a 12 tout à fait
donc ça fait 4 3 pour pour kramnik après
cette les organisateurs selon les
organisateurs et d'après la police il ya
encore 4 2 et encore que mais bon il
faudra il faudra faire les comptes à la
fin voilà donc on se donne rendez vous
maintenant pour la huitième partie donc
c'était une très belle septième partie à
revoir je pense à analyser très belle
partie d' attaque avec une excellente
défense de l'autre côté et contre
attaque tenue dynamisme du snc du dépôt
échec ce matin début du très beau jeu
toujours à demeurer à vider vos joueurs
à très bientôt pour la prochaine partie